freue mich sehr dass sie so kurzfristig
zugesagt haben weil wir tatsächlich auch
über ein gesellschaftliches thema vier
verhandeln
und ich muss jetzt mal so explizit und
deutlich werden das noch nie gemacht
aber ich mache jetzt zum ersten mal was
haben sie gedacht als sie erfahren haben
dass ein gericht entschieden hat dass
sie sich beleidigungen wie und ich
zitiere jetzt stück scheiße altes grünes
dreckschwein drecks [ __ ] sondermüll
alte perverse [ __ ] gefallen lassen
müssen
unglaublich also die begriffe selber
sind ja leider begriffe die im netz des
öfteren fallen männer ins bonner männer
die glauben so mit anderen menschen
umgehen zu können
insofern haben mich nicht die begriffe
entgeistert sondern ein gericht das zu
einem dieser begriffe sagen ja das ist
haarscharf gerade noch hinnehmbar
wo ich denke er war dass wer hat das
geschrieben wer hat das entschieden also
das kann man gar nicht sich vorstellen
weil und es gab im netz auch beim
postillion wir haben das einfach mal
umgedreht und dann siehst du auch wie
unglaublich das ist wenn man all diese
begriffe über ein gericht benutzen würde
ja dann würden wir alle sagen wenn jene
zunächst jede schülerin jeder schüler
der das 2 3 mal sagt pflicht von der
schule her und jedem kind würden wir
sagen so redet man nicht miteinander und
würden es mal freundlich und
nachdrücklich zu einem intensiven
gespräch bitten über wie man sich
benimmt und dass richter das
entscheidend mitten in deutschland habe
ich für unfassbar gehalten und dann ich
meine so im laufe der tage glimmt in mir
aber auch ein richtiger ärger auf wann
ist sagen also habt ihr eigentlich den
kontext nicht gesehen in dem wir uns
bewegen ja es gibt ja nicht einzelne
leute die das normalen browser manche
setzen dass systematisch also sie haben
dann auch rechtsextreme die das
systematisch 1 augen auch in diesem
kontext gestellt also ich fand
eigentlich nach und nach alles unfassbar
sowie ari miert mich aber da noch weiter
zu kämpfen
sie haben geklagt weil sie wissen wollte
sie hätten die leute sind es waren und
sie wollten so zu sagen sie wollten
sozusagen sicherstellen dass sie sie
wollten facebook den großen tech konzern
aus amerika zwingen die klarnamen
rauszurücken das war die idee her ja
zwei es sind facebook und twitter
das sind die sogenannten bestandsdaten
also ein paar daten zu der person damit
du die auch ausfindig machen kannst man
kann nie sicher sein dass die die war
also alles haben aber bestandsdaten ip
adresse usw
als vorbereitung für eine
zivilrechtliche klage und deshalb haben
wir das auch alle zusammengefasst
mehrere vorfälle in jeweils einen antrag
zusammengefasst um das sozusagen
abzufragen
deshalb kam das auch mit dieser wucht
zurück das haben sie plötzlich so viele
begriffe was ihn dann mal zeigt anders
als wenn du jetzt alle paar monate eine
einstellung bekommt von der
staatsanwaltschaft wo ich auch schon
ungeheure dinge hatte ja nicht nur
ungeheuer der text sondern auch
ungeheuer das sind generalstaatsanwalt
schreibt zum beispiel von ihnen würde
ich gerne eine enthauptung video sehen
im zusammenhang muss im um gewaltbereite
islamisten ging oder terrorismus so
schreibt einer von ihnen würde ich auch
gern eine enthauptung videos ihren
beleidigende herabwürdigen da geht es ja
nicht mal weil man eine ahnung hat wie
die funktionieren öffentlich vorgeführt
und also was du auch nach der beschwerde
wurde mir mitgeteilt dass es nicht ich
kann gar nicht so viel verfahren machen
wie ich mich drüber ärger aber jetzt
muss ich ja da weitermachen um weil ich
die auseinandersetzung über noch die
gesellschaftliche entwicklung eng sagt
und es aber der punkt warum wir heute
auch darüber sprechen bevor wir auch
gleich die runde nochmal weiter
aufmachen r scherzt nicht nur sie sagen
dieses urteil ist nicht hinnehmbar das
ist ein skandal wie kommt es zu dem
urteil
also ich habe das gelesen ist ein
beschluss ehrlich gesagt also ein
beschluss ist wichtig genau aber ganz
kurz es gibt tatsächlich darum dass frau
künast auskunft wollte von facebook
ireland limited
wer die hater hinter diesen namen sind
wir haben ja das phänomen und das
problem sogar doch mal anonym hetzen
kann und deswegen bleibt das den
betroffenen dann nur übrig die
internetplattform zu verklagen auf
auskunft wer war das
und dann müssen die gerichte institute
prüfen ob es eine beleidigung ist weil
nur dann der name herausgegeben werden
muss das ist hier der fall konkret und
das gericht hat ihn für mich offen
gesagt nicht nachvollziehbarer weise
diese ganzen aussagen die sie eben
zitiert haben für noch hinnehmbar noch
sachlich gerechtfertigt und nicht allein
auf die herabsetzung von frau künast
gemünzt bewertet und das ist in der tat
fatal weil wir brauchen in zeiten wo im
augenblick nur noch hass im netz ist den
rechtsstaat wir brauchen dort die
gerichte und den gesetzgeber um diesem
hast etwas entgegenzusetzen
und wenn so ein urteil jetzt diese
begriffe erlaubt fühlt sich der
wutbürger der hate ja geradezu
aufgefordert noch weiter noch schlimmer
zu formulieren und dann eben auch im
bereich von gewaltverherrlichung und
anderen themen zu formulieren das heißt
man macht mit solchen entscheidungen
auch die tür auf für noch schlimmere
delikte bis hin zu gewalt die wir ja
auch schon haben das heißt das urteil
darf stimmt genau aber auch der mord an
dem politiker ist letztlich das sind
folgen wenn der staat wenn der
gesetzgeber und die gerichte nicht
knallhart sagen hier ist schluss damit
verletzte persönlichkeitsrechte und
beginnt straftaten und ich glaube ganz
persönlich habe auch erlebt wenn man dem
sogenannten wutbürger in seinem ganzen
hass mal eine staatsanwaltschaft im
gegensatz oder verurteilung sind viele
auch glaube ich wieder anfangen war
und wenn das nicht passiert wird aber
der hat es weitergehen das heißt dieses
urteil darf keinen bestand haben und ich
kann frau künast nur ermutigen dort
beschwerde einzulegen
nur damit das mal
klar es ist wirklich interessant
mariniert zu machen
in diese in diese begründung rein
zuschauer in dem ein kleines beispiel
raus also ich zitiere jetzt aus den
unterlagen des gerichts die begründung
dafür warum sowas zulässig ist zitat die
bezeichnung der antragstellerin als
hohle nuss die entsorgt gehört und als
sondermüll stellt sich als überspitzte
kritik da da sich der kommentar
erkennbar auf dem post wiedergegebene
äußerung bezieht und damit sachbezug hat
stellt er sich nicht als diffamierend da
ja das ist absolut das hat auch mit
allem was ich an entscheidungen vom
bundesgerichtshof und
bundesverfassungsgericht kennen nichts
zu tun
wir sagen immer wir wollen eine harte
debatte
man darf hat formulieren auch gerade im
politischen diskurs aber die
menschenwürde muss unangetastet bleiben
und wenn es dem sich äußeren hier dem
anonymen wutbürger nur darum geht mit
solchen formulierungen frau künast r
abzusetzen was hier eindeutig kampf
alles es gibt ja keinen wirklichen
sachlichen anhaltspunkt dafür solche
solitären formulierungen wie musiktracks
dazu benutzen
dann gibt es dafür keine rechtfertigung
insofern der witzes ich kenne diese
kammer sehr gut ich bin seit vielen
jahren daher jede woche in der
mündlichen verhandlung war sogar gestern
da die hatten sogar gestern
offensichtlich erhöhten schutz
dort war offenbar auch natürlich über
die kammer geht es auch ein gewisser
schutz darüber davon kann man ausgehen
das heißt dass die das ist also dann
aber gestern justizwachtmeister die
waren sonst bei franzi wir verfahren
nicht ich habe da gestern verhandlung
und da war mit mir aufgewachsen
plötzlich 34 justiz nachweis verstanden
und hinten beim gerichts wurden auch
plötzlich wie taschen kontrolliert das
ist ungewöhnlich und das muss mit der
entscheidung zu tun haben sie danach
gefragt
ich habe danach gefragt aber keine
antwort bekommen aber noch einmal ich
kenne die kammer das sind gute richter
die immer richtig abwägen
ich kann ihnen wirklich nicht ich kann
ihn wirklich ausnahmsweise kann ich hier
nicht einordnen wie die richter zu
diesem urteil gekommen sind zumal die
begründung wirklich dem fass den boden
aus schlägt da fällt mir nichts mehr ein
nochmal aus dem beschluss des
landgerichts zitat die äußerung wurde
diese dame vielleicht als kind ein wenig
viel gift punkt punkt punkt und hat
dabei etwas von ihren verstand eingebüßt
punkt punkt punkt stellt wiederum eine
polemische und überspitzte aber nicht
unzulässige kritik der das ist das ist
wie gesagt absurd und ich mache das 25
jahre ich mache nichts anders als die
frage persönlichkeitsschutz was darf ich
über jemand anders sagen
und so wird sowohl der wissenschaft als
auch als anwalt und ich kenne die
rechtsprechung seit vielen vielen jahren
die ist eigentlich durch entschieden
dieses urteil wird auch keinen bestand
haben kann man sicher sagen ich habe
eine einzige erklärung die ich habe wies
die mutter kommen konnte ist folgende
der ganze sound der republik ist seit
geraumer zeit völlig verwahrlost und
verroht das heißt also die button der
kultur ist zum absurdum geführt was ein
patient ist am arsch oder sollten wir
bis jetzt mehr herz und das heißt dass
das heißt also das heißt das darf man
sagen ja okay weil vielleicht inzwischen
wir alle daran gewohnt sind dass man
dass das dass der sound im netz und in
auch bei den auseinandersetzungen ist in
der politischen debatte inzwischen ja
fast auf den bundestag mit der afc ja
meinen vielleicht ein zeuge das von
allen seiten sei definitiv von allen
seiten
vielleicht meinen richter inzwischen
doch dass sie weil das inzwischen so
verhärtet ist man heute da einen
größeren maßstab walten lassen muss
noch vor wenigen jahren durfte man über
einen schriftsteller nicht stein dummer
autor sagen
man durfte eine fernsehansagerin nicht
aus gemolkene ziege das ist recht
sprechen vom bundesverfassungsgericht
entscheidung sind rechtskräftig warum
jetzt jahre später die aussage drecks
vor zusätzlich sein soll
es erschließt sich wenn ich kann es mir
nur so erklären dass das gewissermaßen
durch die ganze verhärtung ist der
debatten coolste wahnsinn zwischen die
schwer in niedriger liegen auch berichte
was falsch ist der rechtsstaat muss
reagieren die ist ja sehen wir gleich
rüber hoffen
anbieter
sie wollten gerade was sagen brocken ist
ja wann ich an diesen einen punkt nahe
an kämpfe was ich eigentlich
gesellschaftlich verändert und das ist
auch das was mich treibt das eigentlich
weiter zu machen ja ich habe ja noch
eine wunderbare ein verein gefunden der
sich da gegründet hat um sponsorengelder
gefordert hält findet man auch im netz
die sie eben jetzt versuche für leute
die betroffen sind so einige aufzubauen
dass man die zivilrechtsverfahren macht
weil das zivilrecht und das ist
eigentlich hier in diesem fall mein
interesse gewesen
das zivilrecht nimmt ja viel früher eine
ehrverletzung an und bringt mir
schadensersatz oder schmerzensgeld als
das strafrecht das ja immer so die
ultima ratio der letzte punkt sein soll
wo der staat reagiert ja und da wollte
ich eigentlich hin mit der geschichte
will ich immer noch hin das gebe ich
natürlich nicht auf weil ich will dass
die leute sehen das ist finanzielle
folgen hat ja und auch weiß dass
ehrverletzung und starke der
strafanspruch im strafgesetzbuch noch
ein bisschen ein unterschied es muss
aber diese diese reaktion geben und mit
hate machen wir es so wenn ich da mal
gewinnen wenn ich gewinne
krieg ich dann nämlich das geld nicht
sondern ich schicke das gleich an hey
babe damit die geld für andere verfahren
hat oder gibt es da ganz einfache leute
es gibt der junge frauen von freies for
future wieder ein zwei verfahren führen
dass wir wissen dass es also den fall
wittke der ermordet wurde
wir wissen das ist meist auch sachsen
anhalt war das wo ein ehrenamtlicher
bürgermeister sozusagen sein amt
niedergelegt hat ja weil er ich habe
eine flüchtlingsfamilie unterbringen
sollte und hat so viel hass gegeben
analog und digital das gesagt hat ich
muss meine von mir und mich schützen und
das sind so ich kenne so viele fälle von
leuten besonders auch noch frauen ja die
dann so besonders hart angegangen der so
noch immer sogar sexuelle kohle genauer
immer so eine sexuelle abwertende
konsultation auch da habe ich das gefühl
wir müssen den umgangston in diesem land
verteidigen und was nicht sein darf wie
herr scherz gesagt hat dieses das
gericht sich dadurch beeinflussen lässt
also ich meine die legislative die
regierung und die gerichte haben die
aufgabe den rechtlichen rahmen den wir
haben auch zu halten und die menschen
davor zu geschützt und ich glaube wenn
man daran nicht hält und eine rote linie
zieht dann engagiert sich in diesem land
irgendwann niemand mehr
wir werden ja deutschunterricht mit
seinen kinder machen können sich die
übereilt gehalten werden sich aber ein
dass eben die päda demonstriert mit dem
galgen wo frau merkel dran hängt und die
polizei nicht eingreifen oder sigmar
gabriels oder sigmar gabriel oder damals
bei der fest der deutschen einheit wo
der bundespräsident von einem mob offen
gesagt aufs schlimmste beleidigt was ist
das ist der garten den sie ansprechen
welt wir haben es auch in der analogen
welt auf der straße dass diese ganze
sprachkultur verroht es aber auch
inzwischen wirklich leuten faktisch der
tod gewünscht wird und der staat hätte
da reingehen müssen man hätte diese
leute die personen feststellung
durchführen müssen und sie anzeigen weil
sie das ist nicht passiert das ist da
nichts passiert das ist noch nie haben
die weiterlaufen lassen die polizei in
sachsen und die genau so haben sie sich
eingegriffen als kaufanreiz so genau
es ist ein buch das gerade anfang das
staatsoberhaupt zu lassen sonst ist das
einmal kurz anschauen die original szene
die nämlich viel erzählt also über die
die da bröckelt aber auch über die
repräsentanten sozusagen des staates die
im grunde fast wie ohnmächtig davor
stehen und nichts tun
bitteschön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rostock
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so dass das muss man ja eigentlich darf
man das nicht zeigen aber man muss es an
diesem punkt mal zeigen wie man zu
verstehen welcher unvorstellbare hat
sich der band ja die relativ allein die
trainer die tilgen es ist frau merkel da
wurde ja noch andere begriffe benutzt
gehen sicher wir berichteten
das ist die bundeskanzlerin das ist das
werk war das staatsoberhaupt deutschland
es gibt einen eigenen straftatbestand
dass man den bundespräsidenten nicht
beleidigen darf die polizei hätte hier
zumal diese versammlung angemeldet war
und jetzt einfach eingreifen müssen und
dort dieser sache grenzen setzen müssen
und letztlich fügt sich leider dieses
urteil jetzt in diese laxheit findet
sich das vielleicht alles nicht so
schlimm muss man hinnehmen
die streitkultur es härter geworden sich
als 70 alle seien auf der straße wenn
dort der staatliche eingreift und der
netz wenn die gerichte den bürger und
betroffene nicht schützen und man
braucht aber die augen legt gerade weil
es so ist wie wir es ja gerade
feststellen unserer ansehen müssen jetzt
erst recht den rechtsstaat